16 stunden lang steckte er im schlamm
fest jürgen helm will einen neuen radweg
erkunden als er plötzlich bei kirchhorst
unter einer autobahnbrücke versinkt er
wird in letzter minute gefunden bis zum
oberkörper versunken und stark
unterkühlt mit uns spricht er jetzt über
die stunden im schlamm
kurz ausruhen dann weiter wenn eine
recht lustige umschreibung der situation
die rentner jürgen helm beinahe das
leben gekostet hätte
einsatzkräfte zogen den rentner am
montag vergangener woche halbtot aus
einem sumpfloch unter einer brücke der a
7 heraus der 79-jährige ist tourleiter
beim fahrrad club adfc und wollte
eigentlich nur eine neue route ins
niedersächsische altwarmbüchen erkunden
der wasserstand im umliegenden
moorgebiet war an diesem tag niedrig so
beging jürgen helm einen folgenschweren
fehler am anfang noch als nützlich
wurden vergleiche an denn er war
nachfolger der ärger mit seiner frau war
nicht sein größtes problem mit jeder
bewegung versank der radler tief im
morast 16 stunden gilt der sumpf im vest
und mit jedem tritt kann ich immer
tiefer rein
nur wenn ich den einfluss hochziehen
leute dagegen der andere tiefer rein
dann habe ich mich nach hinten auf
doping asics gelegt mit dem ganzen
rücken gesagt hat versucht das bein war
ja gerade körperlich
von der rettungsaktion bekam der rentner
nichts mehr mit denn zu dem zeitpunkt
war er bereits lebensbedrohlich
unterkühlt doch einfach aufgeben daran
hat der rentner nie gedacht für seine
baulichen
habe ich mich besonders abgemüht in prag
nicht die hoffnung aufgegeben
heute ist jürgen helm vor allem dankbar
für den einsatz aller beteiligten allen
voran seinem fahrrad freund der erst auf
die idee kam unter der brücke
nachzuschauen
[Musik]